record surge of post-pandemic Travelers
are hitting the roads and skies to
celebrate the unofficial start of summer
it's the third busiest Memorial Day
weekend in more than two decades more
than 42 million people travel 50 miles
or more that's nearly 3 million more
than last year according to the AAA this
weekend is also the first big test for
Airlines hoping to avoid a repeat we
should say of last year's summer snafu
Chris Van Cleave has more
the great summer getaway is on the vast
majority will be hitting the roads AAA
expects more than 37 million Americans
to drive with the national average for a
gallon of gas over a dollar cheaper than
a year ago David Thompson's summer
starts with a California road trip this
thing takes a lot of gas so it's a lot
of places actually cut you off at 150 so
I have to pump put my credit card back
in and pump again just to fill up this
year Tom Laughlin is trying something
new leaving New York City on Amtrak
leaving stuck in traffic times so this
year we decided to take the train but
the biggest test for summer travel is
playing out at the nation's airports the
TSA screened more than 2.6 million
passengers Thursday alone outpacing
2019. this is why they say get to the
airport early and leave yourself a lot
of time this is the TSA line in terminal
one here at Chicago O'Hare it stretches
almost the length of the terminal
and that's just the beginning Dennis
Salisbury is worried he didn't leave
enough time to catch his flight to
Savannah look
Ed way too long through four passengers
welcome to board U.S airlines are hoping
the combination of increased Staffing
and generally good weather this weekend
helps Turn the page on last summer when
more than 45 000 flights were canceled
we got here still the Bartley family
drove over five hours from Kentucky to
get a non-stop flight for their 25th
anniversary trip to Hawaii we did book a
direct flight because we didn't want to
deal with um any kind of layovers and
issues with the airlines this southwest
pilot really went the extra mile to get
his passengers to Sacramento crawling
through a cockpit window to unlock the
flight deck door after a customer
accidentally bumped it closed during
boarding that Southwest flight actually
arrived early once they got the cockpit
door unlocked looking ahead to Monday
another very busy day at the nation's
airports but Airlines tell us they've
seen a double-digit increase in bookings
from last year for Tuesday and Wednesday
a sign that Memorial Day is no longer
just a three-day getaway
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Chris Van
Cleave in Phoenix